there you go you're wearing it I'm
wearing it yep tell me the news we found
42 all right do you want to see what it
is yeah all right you ready - 805 3/8
all cubed + 804 5 cubed plus 1 - 6 3 1
cubed all right there we go
and why is this significant what was was
43 bit of a milestone in this field of
endeavor so this started a computer
search from way back in 1954 they were
looking for the numbers up to 100 to see
which of them could be represented as a
sum of 3 cubes and we've now just
answered that 65 years later so this is
it this was the last one this was the
last one
yep it takes 17 digit numbers to get
there that's why the of course they had
no hope of ever finding it in 1954 I saw
you recently when you'd found 33 and you
used a big computer not far from here at
the University of Bristol that's right
was this one found by computer at the
same computer no this is actually much
bigger so we had to go another order of
magnitude beyond what I did for 33 to
find this so I actually think the most
interesting aspects this time around
were we're sociological rather than
mathematical so after the 33 news I got
lots of offers of help had turned most
of them down actually the first thing I
did was go straight to Dru Sutherlands
that's MIT
he's world experts at this sort of thing
we teamed up and you know modified the
code to make it run in a much bigger
scale the other thing was we got a big
offer of help from charity engine so
they harness the power of millions of
volunteer pcs okay and they gave us a
computing platform that's you know
massively larger than anything I can get
as an academic and that's how we found
it so some of the people watching this
video if they're involved with charity
engine may have been involved with the
discovery that's right yeah okay how did
you find out how did you find out that
they'd been the breakthrough what how
did the news get to the charity engine
guys
email lists with the solution right did
they did the e-mail say great news is
amazing or was it really perfunctory
email just said we have a solution
serious come on sure it'll take me a
minute to dig up how did that feel when
you saw that would you just like yeah oh
you like ya jumped up and down in your
underpants oh I didn't do a jump for joy
this time but yeah it was pretty
satisfying to solve something you know
that's been out there for four decades
we're not finished of course okay so the
next number after 42 known known
representations is 114 that doesn't have
quite the same ring to it but there's
actually another number that we care
about more and that's three k equals
three so the reason this gets ignored is
there's a couple of small solutions
actually you want to have a go all right
three yeah three okay well one cubed
plus one or they have to be unique so
one cubed plus one cubed plus one key
yeah very good okay and if you play
around for a little longer there's
another one you can find and it's four
cubes plus four cubed plus negative five
cubes so 4 cubed is 64 another sinks for
takeaway 125 is 3 a mathematician called
Moore del asked in 1953 if these are the
only two solutions and we still don't
know that's kind of what kicked this
whole thing off that's why in 54 they
started looking they were hoping to find
a solution for three we're gonna throw
everything we have at it and we'll see
but you know with this kind of thing you
never know it's once in a generation
kind of thing so are you gonna throw any
resources at 114 or is it just getting
silly constantly going up and up and up
yeah so there's another 10 below a
thousand which would be the next
milestone I think I'm ready to hang up
the hat after we have a go at 3 yeah so
you'd rather get a different solution
for 3 than the first solution for 114 is
right here there are 10 numbers below a
thousand that you haven't got that's
right only 10 yep that's right so there
were 13 when I started this
I found 33 and then 795 and we just sent
42 well congratulations
are you gonna celebrate your doing
anything to celebrate it's my wife's
birthday today so yeah you go to a nice
present flowers maybe I think so yeah
and so if we just look at the numbers up
to a hundred so let me say k less than
or equal to 100 the interesting thing is
for K less than a hundred we now only
have two more numbers to worry about who
knows it may well be that if you just
look up to 10 to the 16 you'll find a
solution